le roi c'est michel aumont a été
formidable et sa fille c'est vous ouais
et alors qu'est ce que c'est que cette
jeune femme elle est naïve
nous en parlerons tout ça tout à l'heure
j'ai pas fait ce très distingué
princesse c'est une princesse et j'ai ça
merde
cette princesse voir arriver dans sa vie
un playboy alors qu'est ce que c'est
c'est eh bien si c'est oui c'est un
playboy
ces conditions là c'était difficile
c'est un playboy qui à la suite d'un
pari va me plaît comme je n'ai pensé
dément
gates qui veulent des choses avec le
bouquet non écoutez moi je lançais
confettis chaque fois que je sais ce
playboy intervient donc dans l'existence
de ce principe dans cette cour et ils
vont en arriver à as épousé nous allons
regarder la répétition du mariage car
tout doit se passer dans la convention
bien établie